so elon musk has bitten off a lot here
he's famously smart he probably
understands that but what is it like to
run
a digital media property that's maybe
out of step
with the hurt well dave portnoy's been
doing that for a long time he funded
barstool sports and we thought it'd be
worth asking him what it's like so dave
portney you don't run a political site
but you you know you don't want to be
controlled they've gone after your
personal life they really like actually
tried to destroy you for real
what do you think elon musk is in for
well he has one big advantage over me he
controls now twitter and he's the
ultimate say yeah you know elon said
something that
uh wrong true to me he said if you're
running this correctly the 10 on each
side are going to hate you and that's
the thing about this whole elon musk
buying twitter
and i i even when i come on the show you
know tucker i always say people think
i'm political but all the complaining is
from one side it's all from one size not
from the other you just want an even
playing field if somebody says something
about you you want the ability to
respond what i find happens you know
there's people i'll make up a name julia
hack
there's people like this they'll should
throw shots at you and when you respond
on twitter they have an army of bots
people who say harassment harassment
harassment and they get you banned so
they throw all the arrows and if you
respond in kind once or defend yourself
you get banned or you get in trouble i
think that is essentially what spurred
this on for elon because he got muted
and he's just saying hey let's open the
playing field exchange of ideas i don't
think anybody's saying somebody should
run around be like i want to kill your
mom i want to kill your mom i want to
kill your mom no but if you have an idea
a thought you criticize the other side
is allowed to respond
but the good news is he's the ultimate
guy he's the ultimate gangster i've said
a million times i wish i could be him if
you don't like me you don't like what's
going on i'm just going to buy you up
and let it run and he said something
very key in a piece you played earlier
it's not about economics so i i mean how
much of that's true i'm not sure because
everything he touches is gold but the
the major thing whenever you look why is
one side all complaining and the other
side isn't that to me tells everything
every give people a level playing field
that's all anybody wants the ability to
speak back and debate points
but why is that i mean what you've said
is the definition of fairness it's how
we conduct sports
and business at its best why is that
such a threat when it takes place in the
media
yeah and i don't i don't think there's
there's an illusion of fairness but
there is no fairness going around you
know there's that account defiant l's
business insider they had a tweet that
said you know how great it was that jeff
bezos was buying the washington post you
know now they had a tweet that said this
is the end of civilization because elon
musk is buying twitter it just depends
what you're looking for but the key
thing is
there is no fairness anybody who's
paying attention there's nothing fair
there's the illusion of fairness and woe
is me we're trying to be fair but
anybody who's paid an ounce of attention
knows each platform specifically leans
certain ways and you know what the
craziest thing is i like instagram or or
the facebook or zuckerberg i feel like
they censor 10x what twitter does they
all do it and they all lean certain ways
but there's nothing wrong with fairness
but you're an idiot if you think these
are neutral platforms any more so than
certain newspapers lean certain ways or
even fox news or cnn if you think those
two are looking at every subject down
the middle well your head is in the sand
and it's the same with twitter
right all you can ask for
is clarity
and
giving other people the opportunity to
respond and that's what he's promising
and
literally listen to anything elon has
said i don't know why anybody on either
side would have a problem with it he's
literally saying he wants to play dead
down the middle and wants 10 on both
sides to be like this is wrong that's
how he knows he's been doing right i've
never heard anything political about
elon i think it boils down you know what
as simple as it is as stupid as it is
he's gonna bring back trump i think that
like that's a lot of what people are
freaking out about no that's i think
you're totally you're absolutely right
dave portland great to see you tonight
thank you so much for that subscribe to
the fox news youtube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from tucker carlson tonight